Blackout in Odessa und mehr als
anderthalb Millionen Menschen sind in
der südukrainischen Region vorerst ohne
Strom Russland soll zwei
Elektrizitätswerke der Stadt angegriffen
haben nach mehrwöchiger Pause erstmals
wieder mit solchen iranischen
kamikazedonen so Präsident selenski
insgesamt haben die russischen
Terroristen 15 charitron gegen Odessa
eingesetzt in der Nacht zusammenstag
unsere luftverteidiger haben es
geschafft 10 der 15 Drohnen abzuschießen
gut gemacht
mit solchen Stromaggregaten erhalten Sie
sich ein Stück Normalität aber es geht
um weit mehr als die Fußball-WM dennoch
sind hier bloß gerade in der Nacht zu
Dienstag wird die Temperatur unter den
Gefrierpunkt sinken der Winter als
Kalkül russischer Kriegsführung
es ist natürlich die Terrorisierung der
Zivilbevölkerung bei der wir noch jetzt
noch nicht absehen können welche Folgen
sie haben wird wie viele Menschen in
Folge dieses Winters der Kette einfach
sterben werden die Russen versuchen
jetzt den Winter zu nutzen um die
Ukraine in Verhandlungen zu zwingen Ziel
könne auch sein dass ich Moskau eine
taktische Pause verschaffen will um mehr
Truppen und Material an die Front zu
bringen eskaliert ist die Situation
zusätzlich als es in der vergangenen
Woche Explosionen auf drei russischen
Militär Flughäfen gab die Ukraine als
mutmaßlicher Angreifer weiß die Kritik
zurück
die Ukraine kämpft um hier überleben sie
kämpft gegen Putin die versuchen uns zu
vernichten man muss uns hier keine
Lektion erteilen über Moral was wir
dürfen was wir nicht dürfen
Minister in der ARD Sendung Bericht aus
Berlin
aktuell gibt es vor allem im Osten
wieder schwere Kämpfe besonders rund um
den Verkehrsknotenpunkt bachmut in den
letzten Monaten sollen rund 90% der
ehemals 70.000 Einwohner aus der Stadt
geflohen sein anderen Ort sollen
Einheiten der Söldnertruppe Wagner an
der neuen Offensive Russlands beteiligt
sein im ukrainischen Fernsehen sagte ein
Sprecher des Heeres im Osten russland
habe seine Taktik geändert anstelle von
Angriffen größerer Einheiten erfolgten
jetzt Attacken durch kleinere Gruppen
dabei bleibt auch die Gefahr von
weiteren Drohnenangriffen auf die
kritische Infrastruktur real zweite no
deshalb die Stromversorgung teilweise
wiederhergestellt aber bis überall der
Strom wieder fließt könnten noch zwei
bis drei Monate vergehen
ja und wir schauen auf die Situation in
der Ukraine mit dem militär- und
Sicherheitsexperten Christian Mölling
Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen Frau meiner das aktuelle
Ziel der russischen Regierung ist ja
offenbar die systematische Zerstörung
der ukrainischen Infrastruktur inwieweit
geht denn diese russische Strategie auf
weisen Wettlauf gegen die Zeit auf der
einen Seite muss Russland um mit diesen
infrastrukturangriffen erfolgreich zu
sein große Wellen fliegen denn man muss
es schaffen die ukrainische Luft Abwehr
quasi zu überwältigen das heißt also man
muss mehr Angreifer haben als man
Verteidiger hat wenn man das so einfach
ausdrücken will und auf der anderen
Seite wenn Wellen erfolgreich sind die
durchkommen beginnt die Ukraine ja
sofort wieder mit dem Wiederaufbau der
Infrastruktur das heißt also auch das
ist sozusagen dann die Frage wie viel
Material aber auch wie viel Menschen
sind da um tatsächlich die Infrastruktur
schnell wieder herzustellen das ist im
Grunde genommen die Frage von Mist von
Erfolg und misser folgt die darin im
Grunde genommen begründet liegt der
ukrainische Außenminister collaba der
hat schon gesagt er hält es auch für
möglich dass das ein allgemeinen
Blackout geben könne wie lange könnte
die Ukraine das denn dann durchhalten
das ist sehr schwer zu sagen das hängt
ihr davon ab wie Lokal dann andere
Energiequellen verfügbar sind also wir
reden auf der einen Seite hier von der
zentralen Versorgung mit Energie aber
auch mit Wasser die Frage ist wie weit
man sich anders behelfen kann das kann
man so einfach allgemein nicht nicht
beurteilen klar ist aber je kälter ist
wird umso schwieriger umso dramatischer
wird die Lage umso weniger Tage sind im
Grunde genommen Zeit um eine solche Lage
auszuhalten wir sehen aber gleichzeitig
auch dass die Ukraine wenn sie weiterhin
vom Westen unterstützt wird sie sehr
wohl in der Lage ist in hat doch relativ
kurzer Zeit Infrastruktur Lex wieder
abzudichten und im Grunde genommen die
Infrastruktur wieder herzustellen aber
es braucht Hilfe aus dem Westen
ansonsten wird es nicht funktionieren
jetzt haben sie die Hilfe aus dem Essen
schon angesprochen der ukrainische
Botschafter sagt Deutschland habe auch
weitere militärische Unterstützung
zugesagt heute Tagen auch die EU
Außenminister dazu also wie sehr würden
Waffen jetzt noch mal helfen wenn wir
eben auch sowas haben wie ja Ausfälle
beim Strom und Hunger
die Kämpfe gehen ja weiter und das
militärische Ziel bleibt wir gucken
zurück auf einen Herbst der verpassten
Chancen für Deutschland und für Europa
die Ukraine militäre stärker zu
unterstützen denn wir sehen ja auf der
anderen Seite dass die Ukraine sehr wohl
militärisch erfolgreich sein kann und
dass die militärisch nicht besiegbar ist
dieser Krieg wird noch lange dauern von
daher macht es Sinn endlich den Blick
nach vorne zu werfen und nicht nur auf
die nächsten Tage und Wochen sondern
auch auf die nächsten Monate zu gucken
und sich zu fragen was braucht die
Ukraine um den Krieg 2023 erfolgreich
führen zu können und damit zu einem
schnellen Ende dieses Konfliktes zu
kommen ja und was wäre das dann was die
Ukraine braucht ihrer Meinung nach sind
das dann doch die Panzer westlicher
Bauart
das sind die Panzer westlicher Bauart
denn also auch dieses flüchtende
Argument dass wir den letzten Wochen
Monaten gehört haben man hätte jetzt ja
genug russisches Material erbeutet das
stimmt für einen Moment aber wir haben
es hier quasi mit einer flussgröße zu
tun diese russischen Panzer werden immer
wieder zerstört und irgendwann gibt es
keinen Nachschub mehr das heißt es ist
völlig absehbar dass die Frage von
Kampfpanzern Schützenpanzern auf
deutschen auf die Europäer zurückkommt
das mag sehr unangenehm sein aber es ist
letztendlich nur noch eine Frage von
Wochen und Monaten bis diese Frage sehr
heiß wird diskutiert werden wird weil
die Ukraine dann tatsächlich an der
Front gar kein Material mehr haben wird
und B sie aber neue Chance hat mit
solche Material tatsächlich Gewinne zu
erzielen das heißt sie plädieren dafür
welche zu liefern so interpretiere ich
das jetzt Frankreichs präsent macron hat
ja Verhandlungen auch mit Russland ins
Spiel gebracht sehen Sie dafür momentane
Grundlage oder wäre das jetzt der
falsche Weg
dass der französische Präsident das
gesagt hat ist glaube ich allgemein
nicht als total schlau aufgefasst worden
zu meiner von Sicherheitsgarantien für
Russland gesprochen hat wir haben es
hier zurzeit mit der Situation zu tun wo
die Ukraine im Wesentlichen die
Unterstützung braucht es ist sicherlich
richtig immer im Gespräch zu bleiben mit
Moskau das ist man aber auch das ist
auch der Bundeskanzler das ist aber weit
entfernt von der Frage von Verhandlungen
Moskau selbst hat noch einmal klar
gemacht was die Bedingungen sind nämlich
quasi die Faktur die alten Kriegsziele
sind weiterhin da also ist die Frage was
ist die Grundlage von Verhandlungen es
ist ein gewisser Art und Weise eine
Nebelkerze die insbesondere in
westlichen Gesellschaften verfängt aber
tatsächlich ist es so dass es zurzeit
keine substanzielle Grundlage für
irgendwelche Verhandlungen gibt es auch
der Bundeskanzler noch einmal
unterstrichen von daher geht es nicht
darum dass wir nächste Woche liefern
neues Material sondern es geht darum die
Vorbereitung die systematischen
Vorbereitungen zu treffen damit wenn es
notwendig ist tatsächlich man Waffen
liefern kann das heißt man muss
personalausbilden man muss gucken wie
viel Munition ist ist für den Kampf von
Schützenpanzer vorhanden und wie kann
ein permanenter Fluss von Material und
aber auch von einsatzversorgung
Instandsetzung in den nächsten Monaten
gewährleistet werden sagt Christian
Mölling Forschungsdirektor der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
ich danke Ihnen